welcome to this new tutorial federated
learning is divided into an approach
that brings model training processes to
the training data
federated learning addresses some
privacy and compliance concerns related
to data creation but introduces new
challenges with respect to
infrastructure performance and
robustness
this video aims to help developers and
researchers who are interested in
building novel proof of concept for data
land solutions using flutes
during the following 20 minutes we are
going to explain our vision for flute
the main architecture
a walkthrough of the relevant components
the prerequisite before implementing
your machine learning model solution and
finally a live demo of how to
incorporate your machine learning model
into federated learning environment
we are assuming that you feel
comfortable working with python or
pythorg and have a good understanding
about how federated learning algorithms
work however this last point doesn't
represent an obstacle for the developer
side
before continuing we highly recommend
you working on linux or windows and
installing anaconda and mpi beforehand
so you can run smoothly on the last
handsome part of this video
while several open source frameworks
have been developed to enable federated
learning solutions fee offer end-to-end
simulation
a simulation platform can play an
important role in enabling researchers
and developers to perform
proof-of-concept implementations and
validating their performance before
building and deploying in the wild
the main goal of loot is to be a high
performance simulation platform that
allows quick prototyping for federated
learning research
tuite has a number of characteristics
that enables the user to prevent future
scenarios before implementing the
solution in a production framework such
as privacy tools communication
strategies and scalability
fluid also provides an optional
integration with azure ml workspaces
enabling scenarios closer to real-world
application and leveraging the platform
features to manage and track experiment
parameter sweeps and model snapshots
how does it work
every time we execute flute we are
launching a job that consists of one or
more independent nodes that can be
physical or virtual machines that can
execute optical workers which are
independent os level processes
a working can be either a client or a
server during each iteration round the
orchestrator which is the worker serial
dispatches the central model to the rest
of the workers and then queue a subject
line tasks for workers to execute
the workers receive that line task which
is basically the training data plus the
configuration of the task and execute
stochastic gradient descent on the
central model using that line training
date
once this is done the clients send those
audio gradients back to the orchestrator
where they will be aggregated
flute uses the library of message
passing interface well known as openmpi
for its communication backbone which is
defined in federated.pi
once the server is instantiated it acts
as the orchestrator which takes care of
the following
run an initial validation testing round
if the options have been enabled in the
configuration file
set the initial learning rate for the
workers
sample deadlines from the pool of
available workers dispatching training
tests for all the sampled lines and
received back the solo gradients
note that at this point we already have
the cellular gradients for each line and
they come with a specific weight that
can vary accordingly if we are using the
ea which is dynamic reading aggregation
or fed average
perform aggregation
and finally some round stat and profi
and profiling steps
let's move on to client all of the
processes to compute the gradients that
are delivered to the server happen here
each independent line performs the
following
whereas the configuration test prepares
the line data that will be sampled for
training
initializes the model optimizer data
loaders and the scheduler
performs several iterations of the
training on the client's training data
estimates the federated optimizer
weights such as the ea or fed average
and finally prepares smaller parameters
to be transmitted back to the server
how do i build my federated land
solution using flute
during the following section we are
going to explain what are the steps to
follow in order to create our federated
land solution with flute
first we need to incorporate our machine
learning model previously frame it in
python
at leaning the standard declaration of
the machine learning model requires the
following five functions inside the
platform
first the constructor with the model
definition and their respective layers
second the loss function that computes
the loss that we are using during the
training rounds
third
the inference function that is used to
perform the metrics used during
evaluation rounds and finally the sets
function that will bring the model into
evaluation or training mode
the example shown in the screen was
taken from the cnn classifier experiment
in
flute second data pre-processing at the
moment flute supports hdf5 and json
formatted inputs and requires a specific
format for the training data which is a
dictionary of the following
users an array arrival with a unique id
for each user id in the training data
user data a dictionary containing the
user index training data in the form of
a dictionary
number of samples and array with the
number of samples for each user in the
same order of the user list
user data label this can be optional a
dictionary with the same structure as
user data containing the training data
labels in the form of a dictionary
the format displayed on the screen is
mandatory because of the design of loot
but we provide some sample scripts for
pre-processing the data into this format
in utils pre-processing folder
the easiest way to start experimenting
with the different features that flute
provides is strokes during the
configuration file while all the setup
for the task are started
flute config files have the following
sections
first modal config contains the path and
parameters if are needed to initialize
the model
second tpconfig
contains a differential privacy setup
and can be disabled
third privacy metrics config this is for
cached data to compute additional
metrics can be disabled as well
fourth strategy for choosing the
federated optimizer we want to use
either gta or fed average for instance
server config determines all the server
side settings
and finally client config dictates the
learning parameters for client-side
model updates
in order to see which parameters can be
used for each section you can find fully
documented examples inside the configs
folder
now that we have covered the basics for
incorporating your machine learning
model solution into affiliate learning
framework let's move to the demo
during this last section we will show
you step by step how to run one of the
tasks reconfigured in flute and we will
demonstrate how each step described in
the previous section was incorporated
for this task
hi there
in this tutorial you will learn how to
run your first federated experiment in
flute
for this you're going to need 3 things
installed in your computer git anaconda
and some implementation of mpi
we have tested both mpi for windows on
windows and openmpi on linux
during this tutorial i'll first show you
how to clone the flute repository and
how to install the required python
packages
next we'll take a closer look at one of
the experiments we have implemented on
the repository where we train the
classification model on the cipher10
dataset
you will see how model data and
parameters are set for this experiment
and how to actually run it in your
computer
with this are you ready to start
this is the website where you can find
the flutekit repository
github.com microsoft slash msr flute
here you can see the readme with the
tell instructions
what we're going to do next is also
describe here
by clicking on code
you can find the url that you use to
clone the repository
we then proceed by typing
git clone
followed by this url
once the repository is cloned you can cd
into it
inside you'll find a file called
requirements.txt
this file contains the list of python
packages you'll need to run flute
we'll first create a new and account
environment called flute
we'll use python 3.8 which we know works
well with flute but you can also try
different versions
finally once the environment is created
we type conda activate flute
and then install the packages by running
pip install
minus requirement.txt
this will install a bunch of packages
and might take some time maybe around 5
or 10 minutes to conclude
in the meantime we can take a look at
how the experiment is specified in flute
here we have opened the flute repository
in vs code
in the experiments folder there are a
few examples that you can use to create
your first experiment
we're going to take a closer look at one
of them classifcnn
there are three or four important files
that we should look at
the first is model.buy which specifies
the model architecture
here we have a simple convolutional
network with just a couple of
convolutional layers
we'll wrap this model using a different
class called cnn
which must specify four different
methods
loss
inference
set evol and set train
essentially digital fluid how one
evaluates laws and output for this
particular model
let's now take a look at how the dataset
and data loader are specified
we have two files inside the dataloaders
folder nevermind the text prefix this is
just for practical purposes but will be
removed eventually
inside the dataset we need to specify
how the data of any given user
identified by user index should be
retrieved
we typically follow this structure for
the data
we use either a json or hdfi file with
this four fields
finally the data loader
simply wraps a pi torch data loader
to get a ridiculate function that builds
batches with a specific format
the last file we need to look at is the
config.yml which contains all parameters
for the experiment including what
federated strategy
is used
how many clients are processed at each
iteration
the batch size
etc
the parameter names try to be
self-explanatory but there are also
comments here describing them
next we'll see how to actually launch
this experiment in your computer
first we need to prepare the data
you need to first run the utils slash
download and convert data dot by script
that will download the ciphertime
dataset and convert it to a hdfvi file
in the expected format
we're going to split the fifty thousand
samples in cifar uniformly among one
thousand clients so that each has 50
samples
looking at the uterus slash data folder
we can see that two hdf5 files were
created since i already ran the script
beforehand
finally to launch the experiment
you can use the command that is
available in the readme
let's just call an mpi with four
different threads one of them is the
server
and the other three workers that process
clients
and then just calling python with the e3
trainer passing data pad
the output pad
the config pad
and the name of the task
we can see that the experiment is
starting
to first run an evaluation round
and then it starts processing clients
at any given iteration it will process
10 clients each with 50 samples
after 50 iterations it will run another
evaluation round
and we'll see it already has a
reasonable number considering the
network we're training is quite small
so here we can see that the validation
accuracy is already 31
after 50 iterations
we hope that developers and researchers
can take advantage of this framework in
the development of new federated
learning efforts and we encourage the
research community to explore new
approaches using flute
for more information regarding to the
implementation please visit our
documentation
we also encourage you to check out our
paper in archive
finally read our latest post on the
microsoft research blog where you can
find more information about this project
you